[Music]
sam tsui ahead wash is the world's first
front load washer with the distinctive
access door that makes it convenient to
add any item such as the piece of
forgotten laundry without having to
drain the water in order to open the
main wash adore mid-cycle it also allows
users to air hand wash items for rinsing
or additional softener anytime during
the cycle consumers can enjoy added
flexibility efficiency and convenience
in their laundry routines the design is
the result of deep consumer insights in
both South Asia and globally when it
comes to laundry in South Asia there is
a strong trend of interacting with wash
cycle for example in thailand housewife
like to add fabric softener at their own
particular time in the water cycle to
maximize the pavements however when it
comes to front loading machines this
interaction is not possible the biggest
challenge faced was the manufacturing
aspect of the more the glass door with a
cutter to meet the desired manufacturing
product quality and costs as such we had
to source new external manufacturing
partners with the right capability
outside of our region working together
with our new HQ
as a designer we believe that great
innovations begin understanding the
needs and wants of people this
understanding is the first step in our
design process research and insights
allows us to consider every possibility
which fuels our ability to create
thoughtful innovations that enhance the
daily lives or consumers
you
[Music]